for
hey what up friends how youall
doing I'm going to go live in just a
minute some hot Doom action keep ey on
the twitch chat thank you all for
joining
us say thank you to the good people of
austral
Asia for hooking us up Doom is not
launching for officially in where we are
in the west coast for another seven
hours 900 p.m. Pacific which I believe
would be that'll be midnight Eastern is
when it all kicks off obviously if
you're in the UK you're probably going
to be getting the if there's midnight
launches I'm not sure probably going to
be getting them pretty
soon but yeah we got it here we got
single player we got multiplayers here
as well I'm going to maybe dump in a
little later snap Maps here too might
jump into that got to play for 90
minutes and then hand it back to Peter
Brown who's reviewing this for Game Spot
thank you all so much for joining us all
right I'm going to go live in a
second
oo there it
is beautiful hello and welcome to a
special now playing they're all special
really today's one man is a bunch of
great games coming out this month
ridiculous Uncharted 4 I'm still playing
throughout myself but uh a great game
coming out on a Friday it's like I'm
back in Europe all over again launching
internationally today is Doom the latest
in the Doom series it's been a long time
since we we had a a main number Doom I
guess we're not getting a main number
Doom we're just getting Doom it's been
12 years I think 2004 uh since we played
Doom 3 which was an interesting
narrative Doom game um the multiplayer
beta for this version for Doom 2016 or
whatever you want to call it was a
couple weeks ago it's kind of uh maybe a
[__] response to it not really being
made it's kind of being developed that
was being developed outside of vid by a
team who's done a bunch of other stuff
like Halo and card so today since we
have the game early uh Rel Tech
technically early for where we are um I
am going to dive mostly into the
campaign to sort of figure out exactly
how that plays because we had a little
demo of it about a week ago on Gamespot
or maybe two weeks ago at this stage and
I sort of came around during that stream
I I didn't think it was I wasn't sort of
sold by a lot of the trailers that I saw
and I think a lot of other people felt
that way as well but after sitting down
and watching and playing the game for an
hour I was actually a lot more sort of
uh interested or maybe optimistic is the
right word to see uh to see what there
is to offer so uh without any more Irish
man talking without any picture and
picture let's jump into Doom so here's
the uh splash screen we' got multiplayer
campaign and snap map I've had a little
bit of a look at this earlier on and uh
it actually La if you go into one of
these it actually asks you want to
relaunch the Doom in Doom in a different
mode so that's a little bit weird we
might jump into some of that later but
for now let's get into the campaign
Peter Bryan's playing at the moment he's
a couple of hours in going to start a
new
slot start campaign here's all the
various uh
difficulties I
mean maybe for the sake of showing it
off I just might do it on hurt me plenty
I feel like Ultra Vance is probably the
way to go nightmare mode apparently is
pretty difficult Ultra nightmare I
believe means if you die you you don't
save your progress or something you can
save your campaign upon completing a
mission or dying and dying or failing in
Rune TR will not affect your progress
but otherwise if you D campaign uh it's
over and a death marker will be left
behind as a reminder of how far you
progressed I believe nobody at eight has
completed it in that mode yet uh for the
sake of this I'm going to go hurt me
plenty I want to show off the game to
you
all so let's drive in H I am playing
this on the PlayStation 4 I believe
unlocking this via steam involves a lot
more jiggery pokery than maybe we were
willing to do valve was also doing a lot
of banning at the moment so maybe not
the best
time H but uh it looks pretty good for
PS4 for game I'll say that as well and
let me make I'm going to turn the audio
down a little bit probably give me a
little heads up make sure the there's a
good balance between me and the audio
here console loading
times I mean it's the start of the game
it's usually a big load you know what I
mean 99% all right here we go they are
rage brutal without Mercy but you you
will be
worse R and tear until it is
done
yo this gun isn't that
powerful all right first things first
this game looks pretty
pretty I just woke up in some sort
of stone
tomb looks like maybe I was just cut out
of it I don't know let's keep going
hooray the awesome
uh screens from Doom 3 are back which is
pretty
good oh okay and apparently I'm some
sort of a God that's pretty cool we have
to contain
this all right I like the I like the
premise that Doom God is some sort of
hell destroying demig guard that's
pretty cool and this a moment for all
the halflife
one and two fans out
there yeah
baby I don't know what that symbol means
presumably that's a nice narrative
effect
uh for a second there I thought we were
going to go all Star Wars
uh what was the name of us Rogue no I
forget the name the first person shooter
with the with the visor on
it there are quite a lot of options in
terms of the hood and whatnot which I
will show off in a little
bit cannot determine the cause of the
Demonic Invasion until the res satellite
is brought back online
also interesting uh that the map that
they showed there was is quite evocative
of the original Doom welcome I'm Dr
Samuel this facility I think we can work
together and resolve this problem in a
way that benefits us both yeah [__] you
iPad all right let's go play some
Doom uh this is running in 60 uh for me
I'm not sure obviously depends on your
stream not sure what we're putting in to
be completely honest uh it looks great
for a PS4 game as well Glory
kills so the glory
kills were sort
of a lot of criticism for them uh a lot
of people had myself personally
too according to Peter who's been
playing this for a couple of hours they
actually work pretty good they also give
you ammunition and health so it's sort
of used as a a tactic within the game
kind of the way in Bullet Storm a lot of
those melee kills were used to uh
in a in a sort of a tactical way combat
shotgun obviously we haven't got any of
the mods or anything for this stuff yet
there was a lot going on here in fact H
you upgrade your suit there's all the
the monsters have their
own sort of data entries as well which
is interesting because it actually does
background information on all of them so
I'm looking forward to seeing some of
those what else we got there upgrade
points there and obviously the the map
which again is quite aoca of of Doom
Doom 1 and two obviously a bit more
detailed anyway let's keep
going I putting at 30 trust me it's it's
pretty
buttery all right imps are back Presence
at unsafe levels lock got a backr on the
imps that's
weird so they throw fireballs and you
dodge fireballs and that was basically
what Doom was all about back in the day
was about projectiles that had a
different sort of Speed and Cadence to
them and you trying to manipulate your
way around
them so this thing in the middle is what
I I believe it's called a Gore nest and
essentially every time you disrupt one
of these it starts a wave based
situation so it'll tell us
here demons don't like if you mess with
the gor nests so they're going to turn
up all right let's face some
Doom
Dem
presence come on jump down jump down
jump down on this
thing I just punted that guy that was
pretty
good get some more of
this Wonder can I melee that guys those
guys off the wall
no
again this is early in the game I
imagine they're not being particularly
difficult when it comes to the bodies
you're
encountering
[__] level
lock I mean in terms of movement it's
this weird Middle Ground between quake
and doom where I mean Doom one didn't
have a jump
button
it's got the sort of locomotion of a
quake game though where you're always
sort of pushing forward a little
bit all right where's the last
one can hear you I can't see
you all
right he's just hanging
out Okie doie goret done eliminated lock
down disengage
H all the gameplay that we have we have
a bunch of gameplay hitting to S side at
the moment as well so if you want to see
this in glorious 10860 gamespot.com will
have you back pretty soon we're also
recording this locally as well as we'll
have even more stuff up in the site
later on I'm willing to take full
responsibility for the horrible events
of the last 24 hours but you must
understand our interest in the world was
purely for the betterment of
mankind everything has clearly gotten
out of hand now
yes but it was worth the risk I assure
you all right I like that first things
first level transition in an elevator
check this is a doom
game it's a sweet progressive
metal I mean it's not quite 9 in nails
but all right hitting Mars surface
already
apparently
okay toop down to get your mission
objectives open the dossier with
here challenges exist within each level
as well which are for additional perks
did they just want me to jump down here
all right there your fall
damage no sign of any uh oxygen meter
from Doom 3 or anything like
that oh a
codec yeah we can we can read that later
on Mars ain't looking too
healthy where am I going am I going in
here am I going
around there a bunch of jerks down
here eat
it okay so I can swap into that one my
weapon wheel is here it slows down time
as well which is interesting so you can
you can have two
weapons open at any one time
whoa there we go so I have to soften
that guy up before I can kill him
probably should have meleed him so it's
interesting I mean I would rather be
playing this on my keyboard I'm a
generally a PC shooter
uh it's fine I mean I'm not getting this
exact Precision obviously you get on a
messing keyboard I'm not necessarily
thinking this game is a headshot hunt
though
so thought that radio was a
there we
go it's fun though I'm liking the
speed okay I I need to kill one of those
guys the next time that happens when
they glow I'm guessing that's like R
time to take them out with one of those
take Downs where's the next
one there we go I'll do it whoa bad
Health there we go
get quite a lot of Health I got like 30
Health off of that one takedown
so it's pretty
meaty all right let me give me a second
I'm the original you know the series The
Doom Series has always been a a finding
secrets and opening areas usually have
some secrets so I'm just got to do a
little bit
of wandering around here when we had
them in for the
demo there were Bunches of Secrets even
in the initial areas
so wonder if I do this
just give me give me a little bit of
patience here let me just [__] no I
bounced straight off that actually I
wasn't even on
the yeah I don't know can you even get
up on these oh I guess I can just climb
up on it
idiot all right let's see if there's
anything over
here no doesn't want to let me up
there got some ammo
anyway so it's almost like Quake
grappling hook style where they're
encouraging you to to bound around a
little bit more obviously you're not
closing the distance or anything but
blue key hooray Doom
games open this open no Circle the
Crouch although I unexpect you'll be
using it all that much uh stream today
is going to be going for about 19
minutes and then I have to get this back
to Peter Brown who's reviewing it for
Game
Spot
did I grab a blue key just
there all right I did get
it find the blue access
key it says it's it says it's
ticked all
right never fun to get okay there it is
shoot my way to
it always fun to get stuck in the first
20 minutes of a video
game are you anything
no oh you want to press R3 on
him that was
pointless guess they're trying to teach
me to pick things
up but then everything else I picked up
I just picked up by walking over it but
whatever all
right hooray
grenades all right let's use
one left trigger for
grenades all right let's keep moving
forward
then
and I guess the take Down's our
contextual as well okay here we
go only had the one
grenade I guess the game is warming up
it's actually getting a little bit
difficult I should probably take one of
these guys down if I want to get some
ammo what the
hell jeez
I even pick that
up pistol
ammo come on
yeah I mean this is pretty forgiving in
terms of a tutorial level but hopefully
the action will kick off in a second
where is it
pointing
you want me to go up there or
not according to the developers quite a
lot of the game is set on
Mars and it's not necessarily the same
thing we had in Doom 3 where you were
spending God this gun is a piece of
dirt H where you're spending the end of
the game in Mars apparently
now you sort of go back and forth
between two Mars quite a bit in this
one all right looks like I just
downloaded some extra map which we can
check out
here also set some schematics for the
suit all right area
scanning don't have any of the upgrades
yet so I guess have to wait for
that although maybe this is an
upgrade yeah looks like it all right I'm
go for area
scanning good stuff uh can the power up
drops be disabled uh yes I believe they
can let's jump into the settings because
there's quite a lot of stuff in here so
you you can swap everything from the
Crosshair style the glory kill
highlights you can kill so I think maybe
you can still okay that that disables
the the part where it shines to let you
know if you can get the glory Kill Boss
health bars can be taken off you can
strip the hood air
completely prompt for interacting let me
see I thought you could take off the
glory kills
completely have a look somewhere else
it's probably not going to be in here
you can change your feel of vision which
is interesting for the console version
in fact let's just do that for a second
let's Crank It Up to 110 and see what it
looks
like turn off the motion blur or mess
with it if you
want see what 120 looks like oh yeah
that's got it that's like this is some
this is some Quake three right
here oh I like this a lot this is
fun yeah this is pretty cool that might
be nauseating for you guys though let me
know okay so these are the mod upgrade
stations that are sort of littered
throughout the
game field Jones will supply with mods
it could be activated with the L2 button
so it's the and down sights button
choose which mod you want it'll be
attached to the
weapon I guess Char
burst or explosive
shot yeah let's go for
explosive still only got one round I
need to fix
that yeah I wonder how 120 affs
performance I mean it's still running in
60 for me but who knows all right I got
17 more
shots let's do a little bit of this in
uh let's do an explosive shot as
well oh that's awesome so when you aim
down sights it does the modifier there's
a cool down on it as well
actually
so you can see the cool down ring in the
middle of
the oh great he shot himself classic
Doom would be Doom unless they get hit
each other and hopefully get in fights
actually it's always
fun so I don't think there's any any
limitation on any meta times I can use
that except for the cool
down
whoa
and I got a little bit of a warning
there when my health dropped down
so presuming I'm going to be hearing
that quite a lot during the play
through oh here we
go whoa bad
timing
so I guess that's the RIS the risk
reward of of taking out guys like that
is that you then don't get to harvest
any ammunition or anything from
them this is fun
though yeah I usually hate melee kills
in games I think the only game I ever
liked that had them was um was bullets
St and I'm getting a very similar five
vibe off of this I cannot stand them
in most games like I can't stand
contextual kills in any game to be
honest I hate contextual game kills in
or even contextual button prompts in
games like Call of Duty can I get over
there
huh let me see if I can get over there
is there anywh ran
no all right all right let's try it
out
awesome secret
yeah Doom guy Funko Pop
situation so apparently they're littered
all over the world as
well collectibles in every map uh each
one will find with unlock a model that
can be viewed I mean yay who cares about
that but at least they're pretty cool I
did see one during the uh the
playthrough last week where there was a
commander Keen one which is a pretty
cool it software reference
so there's nothing stopping me from just
shooting that guy
again but it is good fun
boom damn it
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa almost jumped off the
edge let's try down
here there's a lot of like interesting
just Lanes it almost it feel a little
bit of vocative of uh multiplayer
maps sorry drop my controller for a
second I all my headphones run backwards
here we
go oh he's [__]
up that's pretty good I like that
actually the checkpoints seem to kick in
once you've killed enough people not
once you've gone particularly
far man you going to go full half life
and put me in a
train
oh looks like we're going this way uh
cool good question about the fov that
can be a deal breaker if you can't
change it on Console yeah it's pretty
cool I can set it back to uh 90 if you
guys want as well let's just go back
even just for comparison sake let's just
have a little flick back I do like it at
120 though I mean it depends how close
you sit your television and everything
yeah I don't know I think I prefer it
wide I mean not just might be m
rocket Arena
sensibilities 22 acci
days great sure keep telling yourself
that awesome and you hit elevators to
change levels I quite like
that okay so after that I got one secret
which was the bobblehead or the little
doll I didn't get any of the challenges
I don't think I don't sure there were
any challenges in this one uh and then
the combat I'm not sure if that is the
there are like instanced little combat
areas which exist uh which create
leaderboards that you can do with your
friends or with randoms there sort of
little like how can you kill everyone
with this one gun or how fast can you
kill everyone in this wave based
situation and they're optional and
they're littered throughout the the
levels as well they're like little
portals basically
so uh OMG benu says never like Doom 3
just a dark game with monsters popping
air for scares yeah I mean Doom 3's
monster closet problem was that's kind
of all that game had it was incredibly
linear as well in a way that Doom one
and two were sort of playgrounds for you
to I mean they were linear but they were
linear in terms of you had to get the
the keys in a specific order but they
were games that you you had the freedom
of the level you were in and Doom 3 sort
of lacked that it was very on the rails
sorry I didn't realize I could skip
there yeah not sure if I'm getting the
same oppressive feel you get from those
games where you were always on the
defensive then I am playing on the
second difficulty so walk I am Vega the
sentient intelligence assigned to Mars
after running Diagnostics on the pror
suit it appears that I can activate
optional challenges that when completed
will assist in upgrading Your Arsenal at
an accelerated Pace I have added a
tracking component to your
dossier thanks buddy I can't believe
they gave a story reason for ch Alles
but
sure okay so the challenges there on the
right twer kill two of the possessed
with one trigger pull from the shotgun
perform five Glory kills on the
possessed I think the possessed are just
the base zombies right uh and
also find three secrets so those
challenges will then help me upgrade my
suit which is
nice main power offline all entrances
operation all right let's try and get
get two of these jerks on it on one shot
[__] here we go damn
it come on just line up two of them line
up two of
them there's one bring a friend bring a
friend come
on he's on his
own
low power never a good
sign come
here ah damn it come on two of you stand
together missed it oh I did get it
awesome or maybe maybe it was
separate shut up imp
stuff I believe in
honesty especially now in what will be
your final moments in this world decent
animation there all the rumors the human
sacrifices the hell portal the demons
it's all
true my my sisters and brothers be
thankful you will be the first you will
have a seat alongside them just as I
will in what will become the new world
that they create for us God it crazy
religious people okay uh some folks
asking how I feel about it how it plays
how linear this is uh I would be
reticent to make any sweeping judgments
on this game based on the first two
levels this is a first person shooter
they tend to teach you a lot at the
start so I imagine the linearity is by
the design so if you think that this is
a vocket of of the rest of the
experience I would
probably not suggest that uh I like how
it feels I like how controls which is
super important I like the motion my
sisters and brothers be thankful I'm uh
I'm a lot more interested in this than I
was before I started playing I'll say
that as
I mean it's a little bit on the easy
side right now
but uh the levels apparently open up
[__] that'll do
it in fact there's an open area coming
up pretty soon which I remember from
seeing the the single player
demo oh W that's
cool
whoa there did I kill two of them with a
shotgun
surely
God the sound of the sound of West death
is really good Demon Presence at unsafe
levels
lock all right here we
go I do like kicking those
guys
[__] he's got some
health
whoa eat
it all right so that's pretty good you
can get pretty close to death and once
you strategize
and take care of business you can you
kind of get back in
the the game pretty quick it's not like
you're spending a lot of time trying to
look for many packs which is
good I seem to always have low ammo
though that's something I need to Su
to getting a lot of Health back but I'm
not getting a lot of ammo
back oh what was that is that a chainsaw
chainsaw good stuff and each year he
hardest only the best of the best are
you ready to move on to take on new
challenges to become more than you ever
dream you could be W Matthew saying Doom
was
about let me turn down a little bit W
Matthew saying that Doom was about
making your way through complex linear
levels I mean yes but do you remember
the first three levels of Doom one
straight shooting my
friend we are what 30 minutes into this
so I don't necessarily think that I mean
maybe that's the case later on but I
would not make that judgment on this
game right now
considering of one' been playing for 30
minutes here we go so the chainsaw is
weird it's a special weapon like The BFG
so by pressing Square I use it using the
chainsaw requires fuel the bigger the
demon the more you need cutting apart
demons with a chainsaw will always drop
a supply of a surplus of
ammunition so let's try this out so I
think I've got I'm not sure how many
shots I've got Square brings it
up Jesus Christ okay I guess that's how
you get ammunition in this game
[Laughter]
okay that's pretty
good damn
it let me see what that challenge was
again okay I've gotten two of them I've
gotten the TW for I've gotten that one I
haven't got any of the secrets is the
problem
[__] get some health
get some more
Health en let me put it back off
again that charge one is pretty
meaty it's like the
division my follow this guy is that the
idea all
right what's it say over
here yellow key
card what about in there it's got all
the good
stuff neither of these all
right did I have to watch him is that
what it
was access denied yellow security
clearance requir
all right where you sending me up there
let's have a look at the
map okay so here's
your nonlinear level already I guess so
we've come
from back there I
believe and it looks like it's pointing
me got some
challenges it's not the most descriptive
map in the world if I'm facing so I'm
facing it there it's 30 in front of me
there it's over that direction somewhere
okay so I headed where did those two
things Loop
together two
levels all right just have look
right perhaps I missed something back
here okay there does seem to be an upper
level
here which perhaps I can get up
to
[Music]
going on in there that doesn't look like
good
news only got one more of those bad boys
left yeah I don't think I need to be
coming the whole way back here for this
to be honest all right let's Wonder
forward trying to figure it out I keep
getting Square because of reloading in
so many games but obviously not much
reload going on here seven shots take
them or leave them here at the UAC we
take pride in nurturing a growing
Workforce and each year we Harvest only
the best of
the access should I have followed that
man I am lost I am lost dibl yellow
security requir [__] not a key
anywhere in
sight what about down here I got some
health hey video game go back to being
linear I like that
better oh
hello all right so I got
gasoline but the
chainsaw oh here we go now we're going
somewhere find a secret area maybe not
even I don't necessarily think this is
where I'm supposed to be going to be
honest maybe it
is I'll do
it
eat it yeah I'll beat you up with your
own
hand apologies for that
brief little wander eat it what did I
see here is there something here and you
lock security station for there as well
all right let's let's remember that cuz
I think that might be a place we need to
go Yow yellow yellow yellow yellow so I
guess these are all places we're going
to be going back to at some stage anyway
I'm guessing once I've taken care of
this guy
all right gor nested up
boom oh I love that I love that
Crosshair moving oh that
was
get off that
wall
ammunition
Jesus disag all right that's good fun I
imagine that would be even more fun
well I don't know I can see that being
more challenging and more enjoyable as a
result on a harder difficulty I'll say
that if you just join the stream I'm
playing this
on PlayStation
4 this game is uh sweeping its way
through the world at the moment it's
available in Australia which is how we
got our
access it's unlocking here in the
Americas I believe at midnight East turn
which will be in
approximately 6 hours and 15
minutes yes thank you to our Aussie pal
scopo good
point yeah I get it walkie walkie
walkie okay so here's our mod thing
again let's change to charge burst just
for just for
fun yeah sure punch the Drone in the
face that's a good way to doing it I
think I might have gotten an upgrade to
these as well
[Music]
actually yeah I've got two more upgrades
here so charge burst oh you can upgrade
you actually upgrade the mod which is
interesting so let's go rapid
fire and quick load no I guess I
can't have any upgrades for this suit
anymore no I guess there they're still
across both actually so if you have two
mods available for a weapon you can
quickly switch between them by pressing
up oh that's interesting
okay oh you keep it forever good so it's
explosive and if I press up it goes to
the charge burst which looks
like okay it's pretty good of course
it's locked everything's
locked you got a key card
bro
yellow
whoa there's your doom there's your jump
scare from
Doom okie
dokie so I guess we're going back to the
yellow
area let's use our yellow key
card yeah
so I mean it's not the most open map in
the world right now maybe it opens up
even more but we are doing a little bit
of
backtracking I mean you have to say like
I don't want to give anyone any
shortcuts or anyone any easy time
necessarily that's not my job but you
have to say that a game like Doom trying
to bring it back is a floody nightmare
because you're essentially trying to
oops you're trying to PL audiences which
enjoy those games for several different
reasons while also trying to appeal to
new CRS I think maybe the multiplayer is
an area where they got
that perhaps a little bit too much on
the on the new cred
style what's going on in here is there
anything good in here any sh sweet
swag R 83
um sweet share physics um whereas this
feels like it's a bit
more balanced in that way was this only
for ammunition was there nothing else in
here
really thought they' I thought this
would be at least be some sort of
uh little bit of goodies or
whatever oh how do I get back outside to
that yellow area cuz I dropped in
dropped in from the
hatch oh I do press it God I couldn't
see it because it was written on this
because the popup was the same color as
the screen that's
annoying and because I'm a Noob yeah you
all said
it okay so opened up some stuff maybe oh
yeah here we
go what d down here secret
area I'll take
you all right crater token so that's for
my suit I
believe yes so I have another one I can
use can I spit them between I can't so
frer tokens go between both of
them
uh upgrades improve equipment capacity I
get more
grenades resistance to damage why not if
it's already unlock it's probably
worthwhile whoa okay not
good so the CH there's a decent charge
up on this one which I didn't realize so
I got to be
careful anything else in here is that
it I was sure there was another hidden
thing in
here I guess not all right let's keep
[Music]
going that's the way I jumped in where's
the way I jump
out
here lot of vent
shaft cool back
[Music]
here
so is there a way back up there or do I
have to go back to this guy I guess
access granted so it's interesting I'm
not sure if this is the way to go or if
these are just extra areas no I guess
this is
located and resear
facility IM and day as Assa your loyalty
is more than just a commitment to the
UAC it's a commitment to the future of
thank there's your H Docking
Bay okay so the weapon wheel is now
going to come into effect a bit more I
guess so usually I was hot swapping
between the two weapons using
the uh the triangle button all UAC
employees are subject TOS to their
capili where's now because I've got the
the hot I've got this
guy Sorry by tapping this button but
where now I've got the the weapon wheel
I mean I'm not going to use the pistol
at all
but it means that you have to unless you
want to be constantly pausing and doing
this but it does slow down time you need
to kind of have that One queued up I
guess all right let's do it
[__]
oh here we go quad damage whatever the
hell this is berserk
mode who's
next the TR up b quad in the multiplayer
side oh yeah you run
away thing last long
enough
all right feel like I to get to the
swing of things now I
mean I'll say I'll say this I was
sort of cautiously optimistic about this
game as of a better week ago before that
I was a little bit
hesitant and after playing it now for
whatever 45 minutes or so I don't think
it's exactly Reinventing the wheel when
it comes to first person games but it's
fun this is like fun this plays like a
fun fast like strategic firstperson
shooter in a way that like those old du
games they were simple but there was a
simple strategy to them there was it was
about using the right weap weapons at
the right side most of which I will say
I'm probably not doing it was about
knowing who your enemies and how they
attacked you and using that their sort
of movement against against them and
it's it's got
that in a way that's more competing than
like you know I I basically burn animal
military first person shooters because
their AI is just so godamn terrible but
this is like it's not exactly like some
sort
of incredible new take on first person
but it is a solid so far it's seems like
a
solid uh very
stylish homage to those
games I'm blocking your access to the
facility scanner come to the Vega
terminal and I'll give you what you
need and that almost sounds like the
exact same voice that is the computer in
Doom 3 actually which is a little bit
weird all right where am I going Vega
have to go to
Vega he's usually the what fourth
hardest boss in Street Fighter can't
believe we're playing them
already all where direction we going in
Vega upstairs R the outside around the
outside do I really have to go back down
again let us find out together uh so
this game also has multiplayer obviously
and it has the snap map
section uh I have to get this back to Mr
Peter Brown in about 35 minutes so chat
if you would like to see multiplayer if
you would like to see snap map let me
know I'm more than happy to check those
out as
well okay so I guess I'm using this
thing eat
it hop on a crane man it's taking all
the halflife boxes what is going
on I'm just
kidding
aha a first person
parkour multiplayer snap map please snap
map snap
map uh looks like they want to change so
if you want me to swap over the single
player or swap out a single player let
me know right now cuz I'm probably going
to
unless we have some votes in the
opposite
direction whoa e
[Music]
it all right that's a lot more fun when
you're doing it yourself than it was in
the trailers I'll say that look at all
the look at all the ammo they they
dropped so much ammo and I'm not using
that's the best part it's like rockets
and
stuff
anding multiplayer all right I'm G to
hop in the snap op in a
second what
up one
more I heard you I knew it all right see
what happens if I can I just I wonder is
it going to save at a checkpoint or can
I just punch it right
here
still need that red key is there a red
key dude around here all
right let's have a look at everything
else this will be an interesting
situation actually
because the snap map and multiplayer
aspects of this game apparently want to
boot separately once I go into them so
let's let's discover this wonderful menu
system together snapmap you're about to
restart Doom in snapmap mode
sure
do not adjust your streams this is the
black screen that I'm seeing as
well see you later Neo jet Angel
appreciate you popping
in all right well that's a percentage
screen everyone wants to
see so if you don't know might as well
give it a little bit of a breathing room
snapmap is the map app creation tool
which they are bundling with this on
both PC and console versions of the
game it is a sort of a modular level
design
system where you can snap if you will
different leg level segments together
you can create single player challenges
and multiplayer maps I believe uh they
are sharing them within the app as
well and it have said that they're not I
mean this is where they want to focus
their mod Doge tools I think they're
trying to get sort of the younger
generation who grew up playing games
with in-game uh creation to sort of to
mess around with this a little
bit seems to me so this is where they're
putting the focus I I mean I'm sure
someone will want to do a full
conversion of something at some stage
but presumably you're able to make the
original levels of Doom in this you're
able to make you know somebody will make
Mario 111 I'm
sure whoa that really looked like a
crash right
there ah wait I didn't pre-order
Doom so hopefully this works by the way
I will say that this has not launched
yet in North America we are still seven
hours away so maybe we're connecting to
weird servers I don't know but let's
just jump into this together ourselves
featured Maps there it is straight
away E1 M2 right there manious music
maker 9000
uh okay I'm just going to go if you
don't mind I'm G to go straight into
music maker
9000 exited not real is this this s map
supports two or more players you want to
host new Lobby or search for an existing
one
search hopefully I mean who isn't
playing music maker
9000 can I just do it on my own or I got
to play someone else make some sick
beats with friends it says
so again I mean the only people who are
playing this in North America right now
on a PlayStation 4 are people with
friends in Australia with Australian
credit cards so this may very well not
work but if they've gone like straight
up Little Big Planet on this this is
going to be pretty funny oh start game
sorry it's right there I just started my
own I mean like it's out in australasia
at the moment I'm guessing they are
connecting me with the North American
servers so it wouldn't make would it
makes sense if nobody else is on
here I'm fascinated by what this might
be yeah I mean I would imagine that snap
map is
relatively like a relatively simple tool
set but you never know I mean what was
it with a little big planet 5% of people
made 95% of the maps or something like
that you have those power users who you
know die into those tools and make some
really cool stuff so we'll find out I'll
say that the The Mid Mission loading
wasn't too bad on the this version of
Doom I cannot tell if what's these
loading times is them downloading the
game off the server or not but we'll
find
out all right here we are my first Doom
snapmap level Music Maker
9000 for a second I thought it was going
to be like
[Music]
big oh my God
cowbell what else we got oh a drums oh a
secreter you got to be kidding
me oh my
God
okay that's off B let me do it
again okay it's good be we go a little
bit faster
slower not
faster all the way all the
way why can't I have a sequencer for the
cowbell this is exactly the type of D I
could go for all right let's do fre
jaka I need it's a it's B it starts is
it no it's
[Music]
yeah a [__] let me try
again [__]
[Music]
hooray I'm finally the Doom music maker
of my
dreams Jesus great snap map is as dumb
as I was hoping let's see what else is
here oh this is real vote up [__] yeah
if you're running in the US presidential
elections I'd vote for
you
let's get out of this
Lobby uh no I won't oh I guess I
probably
should what is it we went for I love
Doom I think the name of this PSN
account is I love Doom so let me
just it's probably going to ask me for a
hot password as
well it'll be interesting to see what
snap my looks like in terms
of yeah we're
good terms of its usability don't ask me
for email address and password yay all
right let's let's try one more I I I
think we we we already got like a
absolute Legend of one there let's let's
try E1
M2 host solo
Lobby
and we'll start the game I mean are they
allowing you to upload like custom
thumbnails cuz that's what looks like as
well it's kind of
weird yeah we'll snap some maps in a
real in a hot second desert don't worry
or
dessert I can't tell
one Okie DOI this map should be familiar
to I guess anyone who's played the
shareware version of Doom it's the
second
area I wonder why they chose this over
E1 M1
but we shall
see 53% yeah I think this is it
downloading rather than
loading I mean we got a pretty beefy
connection here oh
80% pretty beefy Connection in the CBS
office you download a steam game in like
three minutes here like a like a 30 good
game so it's pretty pretty hot most of
the time but again who knows North
American Service yada yada yada y
yada good
stuff all right somebody needs to do
like a side by side here what guns we
got oh I've only got one
gun the weapon wheel isn't even
working oh interesting and I I also
think that maybe the
oh let's let's find
out jeez what
the maybe
not red key red
key man I wonder if people are going to
make Quake levels you can make all
the especially with the verticality you
could easily make like the the first
level of
Quake I mean it wouldn't look like
anything like
it
oh no they're still in
here all right there you go got the red
key
card that's probably more emblematic of
what the regular snap map sort of stuff
is but
uh this is back I'll just abstain on
that one how about
that okay let's uh
let's try and make a map how about that
create map I I don't want to spend too
too long in here because I kind of want
to show off a little bit of the
multiplayer stuff we have
basic starts with an it's got to started
an exit so that is the single player
stuff I imagine classic
Deathmatch CTF survival which is wave
based King of the
Hill extraction a map with AI and item
spawn settings reach the exit before
running out of lives that's cool so
that's that's probably going to be
interesting for challenge modes TDM and
Tiny a small template with a start and
exit add your own
gameplay I guess that's I was hoping
that would be some level Lord nonsense
where you like spawn in on your small
but I guess that's just a SMY let's have
a look at tiny just to show it off I
guess don't want to spend too too long
in
here Nara 91 says he's gonna make new
says they're gonna make new town nuke
town sorry not new
town all right this is our snap
map Al so nothing's made so this is me
actually making it or not okay X to
attach we can attach things to it God
this is rudimentary isn't it so what are
you what's
the as I zoom in a little bit
you're a small T junct okay that's just
me able to pick it up there is that what
it is
okay so I can grab it by holding
Square guessing I can't grab these ones
cuz they're the oh no I can okay let's
put that
there classic level design you can stick
something behind the player always
popular right at the start where they
spawn
in okay so they don't connect up so I
wonder if I can
Jesus okay so I can these 90 bends are
all in the same one if I hit L1 or R1 I
go into all these extra types of levels
there's a cross I can make a small one
cross
over let me see how big these get
elevators
always Jesus look at that that set piece
Foundry I think that's what we just
fought in maybe let's stick that
there
okay can I just jump in straight
away I wonder
settings enable option mode Z grid okay
so there's actually quite a lot of
different like things you can do up in
the top left there is a sort of a load
percentage based on the amount of
objects you have memory and Network I
wonder what network is
for maybe that's a separate load that
exists because of if you're if you're
making a multiplayer map I don't know
music on oh wait that's during the
editor that's
different R3 is
style
interesting that the style of the M oh
it's the style of the map okay that's
the style of hair runs got it play all
right I can hit start and hit play Let's
see our sick map
I mean it's no music
maker yeah I probably should have put a
load of enemies in there actually let's
let's have a run around without enemies
and then I'll spawn all the weapons and
or like a BFG and just a shedload of
random
people all right behind
me oh that's what I made that's
cool wait
what sick level design Danny you're
stuck you
[__] restart
Mission let's I want to look what that
Foundry looks like and then we'll we'll
back out space saying I hope you can use
custom assets I kind of doubt
it I think they're I mean like how would
they stop people from just putting every
type of Licensing licensed material in
here straight
away I mean I'll have a little F around
just to see just just in case
but it did look like you could do custom
thumbnail though so there's that maybe
they maybe they expand upon
that wow that's a big fandry that I have
no way of getting
to Suicide lava what a way to
go all right we return to snap M editor
I think we can do better I think I mean
I'm no level designer
person but I'm pretty sure the only way
is
up all right let me rotate this guy how
about
that
great all right now how do we add
stuff where's
stuff where's the stuff
section so these are all map
Things style L3 oh okay you jump in like
that that's good
it's
Stars oh here we go what was
that I just hit X over here for ad is
there any way of getting into viewing
function are these the different
types oh there's a lot more different
one categories in here
actually floor refence size oh it's just
doing them by different
types the middle button no that doesn't
do it
either huh I mean yeah you could make
some pretty trolly levels in this it's
fair to
say okay that actually gives you a much
better idea of what you're looking at if
you do it that way that's
good demons one 0% I know game I'm
trying to I'm trying to solve
that
I don't
know I do not
know press every single button and do
not know how to add dudes unless it's
like a unless it's like a you need to
get down like granular let me try that
let me try and just like you have to tap
to zoom in which is a little bit
annoying select or
two
okay I've selected this now
does that mean I can do anything with
it
okay object mode
up
right okay so you need to select it and
then go into object mode so I'm guessing
it uses all these can I can I go between
levels doing that I can Okay can also
click in on L3 and it'll bring into walk
mode which is cool so for doing line of
sights and stuff uh okay let's let's add
something in
here oh my
goodness speakers World
text here we go okay I well just just
back it up a
second if I go into the monster section
we're going to see spoilers so I'm not
going to do that okay I'm I'm I'll throw
in a kakad demon or something but I'm
not going to scroll the whole way down
because I don't want to see
everything let me just see if I I'm
going to quickly go through to see if if
I can hit a weapon okay again if you
don't want to see all the weapons in
this game I'm just going to spawn a BFG
and then I'm not going
to I'm going put a BFG right at the
start there you go
buddy and then I'll might put a couple
of extra weapons here I'll put a chain
gun do that
one I just don't want to show off
everything for the sake I'm going to
stick a rocket launcher in because it is
Doom okay we'll do that okay is there a
is there an ammunition stuff I can do
here or I can put in a million okay how
many red barrels can we put we'll put in
how about that I'll put in like a
million red barrels and
see and one explosive
situation maybe they're not in here
maybe they're not in here they're just
props interactive how about that power
stations mod stuff you can do all that o
Munitions box how about
that yep just floating in the air great
great level
design stick a light
in what's that light Jesus medium
Sparks a small
explosion let's just have this be the
explosion
room
uh okay here we go no not not C4 UAC
Barrel great that's probably enough
let's see how that PlayStation 4 frame
rate deals with that uh okay let me put
in a cocka demon how about that we's
just put a bunch of cocka demons in so
I'm gonna skip off but I don't want to
show off all that stuff all right Kaka
demon one yep two
three there probably too
many and
for fun let's put a possessed scientist
we'll just put one of them just hanging
out in the middle probably stuck between
the
barrels
I know I said one but
whatever all right can I jump straight
in from here I
can okay this
might crash the game I don't know
probably shouldn't but we'll find out I
mean it's no music maker 9000 I'll say
that but we'll see what happens and once
this is done I'll happens to multiplayer
how about that just for a little
second yeah you're right I should have
come a level designer you're right it's
my real calling I'm interested to see
what happens with
these yes I will pick up all of you
thank
you oh I can only have one at a time is
that right or two at a
time two at a time all right I got this
thing which shoots out molten whatever
that's all right I'll probably not use
that then let's do this and where's The
BFG going hell
shot you The BFG
there we
go let's see if the explosions are
happening where are the explosions oh
they probably already happened okay I
don't need this for I'm just going to
use the rocket
launcher hey guys come over here come
over here hey what's up what's up yeah
come over here yeah Kaka demon come over
here yeah I
just all right that that frame rate
didn't drop
whoa die eat
BFG where are the other ones where are
the other
ones come here you dirty combell
meatball where you
at I don't even need to hit you with
this I just need to hear near
you
whoa how I
thought all right let's try that
again where's my vfg gun oh it's gone
that's a shame chain Gun
Works come back
here
oh yeah oh God I could kill that thing
okay you know what let me just let me
just quickly have an undergo of that
because if we can if I can do one of
those finishing moves on a kakad demon
that's got to be pretty
cool
damn I mean it's running at 60 frames
per second here you guys can't see it
sadly on our stream right now but it is
uh it's looking all right I say that all
right give me one more go of this and
we'll hop it into multiplayer and I'll
check out the the modes on offer see if
anyone's playing here in North America
see if there's any more
extra release date
Breakers yeah words to the wise don't
put
your weapons in the
air you know what actually I think I do
want this
one cuz it was good for taking the m
without doing too too much
damage eat
BFG dead three of them dead
EFG that is pretty good all right you
let's do this I need to get up high so I
can finish you off so to
speak damn
it how do I get up higher I got to
jump
no I can't all right how do I get up
fire I got to see if
I there must be some way
upstairs God Maybe not maybe I just need
to get him
low all right come down where you at
friend come on keep
coming keep coming yep just keep
coming
Jesus that's it stay there at least so I
can okay here we
go damn it I hit
him come a little bit
closer all right fair enough okay let's
get out of here scattle we'll get back
to the multiplayer
mode yeah we're we're not in Australia
we we there were ways of getting a range
PlayStation Network shall we
say um especially if you have an
Australian office
so yeah if you have a friend who's got
an Australian credit card you too can be
playing Doom right now otherwise uh he's
got to wait like 5 and a half hours ah
map
name I call it
Doom
map
01 get all those hot up
votes okay we'll back out into
multiplayer mode which hopefully will be
working fine fine we have PlayStation
Plus on this account
so let's kick into that one see how it's
doing Danny any words on the fact that
Ireland didn't go through the second
year Vision semi-finals I don't want to
talk about that rain one to be honest
that's a that's a that's a culturally
unsensitive thing for you to
say
um no we haven't received review code at
all this is not review code this is
nothing to do with Bethesda giving us
review code
as far as I know they did not give out
early review copies to anyone I know
some YouTubers got it and they were
doing paid for Content uh but no they
didn't give any review copies to any uh
to us anyway I know that for sure I I
believe there are some coming but not
until uh launch day which is
tomorrow so uh we will not have a a day
one review I believe Peter Brown is
putting it together I I don't think
we'll have one ready for day one but
um yeah we we'll have we'll have
something we got this at least I mean
you can read into that too much if you
want like there are plenty of games that
you get already access to which are
massive dumpster fires and there are
games that you don't get access to which
end up being Classics there is no Rhyme
or Reason to us like trust us as people
who work in this industry that's not the
way it works uh but you know from what
I've played today they could have given
us this and we could have we tend to not
review games until we played the
multiplayer components as well uh but in
any case at least we we're streaming it
now Team Deathmatch Soul
Harvest domination war
path freeze tag Clan Arena objective
base modes which is a playlist and then
Ram based modes so there is no straight
up
Deathmatch except in snap
map am I right in thinking in snap map
there
is so here's the hack modules which I
like burn cards then there's you know
customization on the character side
let's just brief look at
that you can change the colors you
change the
types make it green make yourself look
like just a
absolute
douchebag customize the weapons a little
bit make a
green cuz even though your country
didn't get into your evasion you feel
pretty good about it
taunts
all right so maybe you unlock other ones
of those as well I'm
guessing okay let's try to do a map uh
something we haven't seen yet I know
team death match and war path were on
the beta I think domination might have
been as well I don't know freeze enemies
that th your teammates that probably is
awful
um all right you know what
just sure Soul Harvest let's do it again
this game is not at North America maybe
we won't find anyone else maybe we
will we shall see any more questions
please send them in I'm going to be
finishing this up in the next 10 minutes
I need to get this copy back to Peter
Bryan so he can review it for
gamespot.com our review will be going
live hopefully over the weekend I
believe uh we have gameplay going up I
believe this live stream of course you
can rewind or we'll have it at 60 frames
a second
version and gameplay rather breakouts
probably from this pretty soon too I
don't think we're going to find anyone
folks they're probably connected me to a
North American
server I mean there's always snap
map we find another music maker that's
pretty
great yeah let's let's not stay here for
for that whole
thing here is a season pass
thing sends you to doom.com
yeah let's not indulge in that all right
snap map let's go and check out one more
snap map
mode we'll see how it's
doing yeah so I'm very much assuming
they were connnecting me with us servers
which makes sense why no one's playing
this right now because it's not out
yet so I'm interested to see if you can
make Death Match maps
in snap map because that's I pretty I
thought I saw that like just Arena death
matches in no TDM
like oneon-one
or oneon-one on one on one on
one seems a little I mean Doom you know
everyone plays these games differently
but whenever I was playing Doom in the
past it was always just Arena Deathmatch
it wasn't team
based certainly not objective based
and there's no shortage of those right
now in real tournaments Alpha is pretty
solid if you're a UT
fan I I'd just be surprised um if that's
the case especially as the elite
designer of this was also the elite
designer of Quake live the uh Quake 3
browser
based game which uh still running I
think but is it on a subscription model
now I
feel can't remember it's been a
while uh Donnie how many players of snap
map support all right let me look into
that yeah I don't know if there's any
day one patch stuff yet so I don't know
if those load times are going to go down
or
not let me see how
many
um people are supported by looking at a
map specifically because otherwise it'll
take a while to jump into that so one
slot is one of
the um one of the the modes in this can
you count to
10 yeah I think I can count to 10 solo
this one's Co-op Co-op
Co-op then there's ones that tells you
if there's demon players as well that's
pretty cool there's a jump map there
which sounds looks pretty I mean I play
a lot of Counter-Strike jump
maps so let's see how many gets into the
lobby how about
that this one has got 112 up votes and
73 down votes so there's four in this
one I'm sure there's more than four in
some of
them I can't remember how many was in
the music player I'll have another look
in a second
mate will this feature uh Game feature
any sort of Co-op type game modes not in
the single player the multiplayer does
have Team based
uh modes team bit death Deathmatch modes
and snap map allows you to play
alongside other people as
well but no I do not believe the single
player component has any of
that oh Nar 91 says that uh he's been
playing all day in the UK on Team
Deathmatch I
mean I used to live in the UK and Street
dates would be get broken real fast
there so you tended to have people
people in those servers so I'm sure your
UK servers probably have a lot more a
lot more people playing shoot the box
when the Canon reaches 10
sure
n98 7 6 wait
no wait am I supposed to count down from
10 now on my
own
bam okay when it Count's down then I go
got it
okay here we go yeah I'm
ready 100 one 100 2 100 3 100 4 100 5
100 6 100 7 100 8 100 9
100 oh get away really all right one
more throw a grenade at
it video
games zero one two three four five 6 7 8
nine ah God I'm so consistently wrong
12.5 again one more
time Siri set timer for 10 seconds Dam
it to late too
late shut up
Siri oh God okay
whatever see that is the perfect level
to troll someone is great my alarm goes
off it's the perfect level to troll
someone just set it set the set the
thing to countdown to like nine seconds
and then say that it's going to be 10
seconds all right let me see if I can
jump into another one here start at
three was that what I was
doing was it was it was going from the
321 probably I mean if I was hitting
12.5 seconds stupid video
game Onslaught four okay you can see it
there four per map four per map five I
mean four might be the top level let's
have a look
at popular maps and see if there's any
difference in in that four four four is
the
max yeah looks like
four Doom disco
Rumble yep going be yep I don't care
I'll host it happy to host the Doom
disco Rumble
freefor all bust your moves on the Dance
Floor says hash disco
Funk this is so
dumb uh yeah there is a horror mode
Marley uh there is a horor mode in
Snapchat I think it's called Onslaught
is what they called it
so all right let's let's do
it
[Music]
I think legally that's as much as funky
town as you're allowed to
play before you start have to pay
[Music]
royalties all right well I can't think
of a better place to finish this
stream Doom out today on well depending
on where you are
today it's unlocking on Steam at 9:00
Pacific midnight Eastern in North
America if you're in the
UK probably pick it up at
a hot midnight release somewhere if
you're living in Australia you can
already play it ex said on PC ex said on
Xbox 36 sorry Xbox one it's out on
PlayStation 4 which I've been playing
right now I've been dwire thank you so
much for
watching whatever this
is for the past 90 minutes I'm going to
get this back to uh Peter Brown so he
can review it it'll be review for
gamespot.com up the next couple days
along with
features hot
gameplay and maybe some MP3s of funky
town I don't know
[Music]
Jesus Take Care thank you for joining me
I'll see you next
[Music]
time
n
t